- I feel like it's not
good for my insides.
(upbeat cheerful music)
- I love Peeps.
- Peeps are dope.
- I just think food
combinations are weird and fun.
- Peepsa.
(man laughs)
- Who's doing this, the teens?
- The dye's seeping into the pizza.
- Look at this colorful pizza.
- [Woman In Denim] It's pretty good.
- It's so weird.
- I like it.
It tastes like pineapples on pizza.
It's like a little sweet
on top of a little savory.
- It's really good.
(both laugh)
- If I was smoking a blunt right now,
it would be the best
pizza I ever had (laughs).
- Chicken wings?
- Is this, no, no.
I don't want to (laughs).
- Should we cheers it?
- Yeah, cheers.
You know what, this is not bad though.
- No.
- No thank you.
This isn't very good.
(woman in green laughs)
- This tastes like chicken.
- It just tastes like chicken.
- As does everything, right?
- This is bad chicken wings.
I don't wanna blame the Peeps for this.
This is not the Peeps' fault.
- There's no other way to
describe it besides fleshy.
- We're ruining Easter, you guys.
- Ew.
(laughs)
- Oh, oh.
What is that?
- I knew I smelled pickles.
- Yeah, I don't eat pickles.
Ain't even gonna happen.
- I love pickles.
- I love pickles too and I love Peeps,
so maybe this won't be the worst.
- This is a terrible life choice.
(man groans)
- This would be good if
you were drunk or high.
- Well, anything's good
when you're drunk and high.
- Oh, I don't think I can do it.
- It's not that bad.
- Do we have a spit can?
- Did anyone throw up?
- I think a Peep is a really
good thing on its own,
but if you try to put it with
other things, it's really risky.
- Turns out Peeps are the tofu of candy.
You can do anything to
them and make it taste
like whatever you want if
you just try hard enough.
- What I will say about Peeps is that
no matter what you put it on,
they still really make it not awful.
There's nothing with a
Peep that's that bad.
But don't challenge them.